the version of Hakuna Matata that's in
the movie like was all of us in a room
this is far away from each other just
like singing at each other's faces yeah
I know as someone who is not the
greatest singer like it's like having to
play basketball with like LeBron James
is like I felt like a fool new in
theaters this weekend The Lion King what
will you see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
life's not fair is it my little friend
while some are born to feast others
spend their lives in the dark
[Music]
begging for scraps The Lion King is the
main movie to watch this weekend and
this time in beautiful photorealistic
animation this classic retelling of a
story many of us grew up on tells the
tale of a young lion cub named Simba who
loses his father and must come to terms
with growing up and taking his place in
the circle of life
[Music]
now that we've gotten that out of the
way we can talk about the incredible
cast this 2019 remake has assembled to
voice these iconic characters we've got
Donald Glover as Simba fiance as Nala
Seth Rogen is Pumbaa chiwetel ejiofor is
scar John Oliver is Zazu and Eric Andre
keegan-michael key Billy Eichner alfre
woodard and James Earl Jones rounding
out the cast the film also has music by
Hans Zimmer and is directed by Jon
Favreau who previously did a CG remake
of the jungle book while others assist
for what they didn't take a true king
searches for what he can give
run away Simba
and never return this movies for you if
you love the original 1994 The Lion King
you just can't wait to see the cast
bring these characters back to life or
if like me you can easily hear the intro
music from the original Lion King in
your head you know the one
no go ahead try it that is your weekend
ticket what will you see and check back
next week for the newest movie from
quentin tarantino now let's think about
that Lion King song again oh no that's
Samuel Jackson's speech from pulp
fiction
[Music]